if I ever think of scum in England the
first image that comes to my head is
like
all right so I can't even remember a tip
so this isn't a normal to pretend like I
do remember 24 is it 24 52525 oh man
so same old same old YouTube fandom
YouTube fandom like comment subscribe
love hate whatever you make audio
connoisseurs subscribe to ting whatever
your poison is and patreon come true if
your sng firm pick your tear pay your
way
we've got bonus episodes coming your way
well they're live on there now laptop
stickers on the way yeah clothing much
on the way on the way got some good [ __ ]
for you man yeah we've got bad [ __ ] so
yeah I'm excited so without further ado
let's start the ting man that bid to you
I need a sip drug addicts I told you
broth I don't care anymore
random do you know like you know when
you watch adverts and you like you see
these like no I'm not talking about big
boy like adverse like that a sponsor
life is like you got Cristiano Ronaldo
doing like an adidas advert or like C
Ariane we're doing a the the car advert
for Sky Sports well not these kind of
man like your everyday regular day
killer man that ridiculous that that do
adverse for probably like slope or I
don't know whatever like monster for
example yeah regular people that do it
yeah actors regular actor yeah that's
their job bro
like an actual job I see actors like on
on otherwise I think how do you even
what do you do in life to get there like
how do you even two things made me
realize that that someone's job there
was one time I was watching a normal
advert
cart know what it was for yeah saw one
chick on there and then the next week I
saw the same chick yeah doing an advert
for like
the bingo ting that JaMychal between
Jeremy Cole shows yeah he's that bingo
yeah Fox bingo whatever he's bored
yeah Fox he's being oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I hate that and it was her again
and I was like why that's her job
that's actually her job if she's an
advert actor she's an advert to makes I
just don't get it because you've also
got people in a background that do add
fact in as well like that's really extra
in an advert you're an extra in an
advert that's boring do you even get
paid for that probably do but like it's
probably shillings
I hate ever I think Everett people get
paid at the peak other people do get
paid but it's like it's like the extras
year
it's like problem I said when I said
proper obviously every other is a
provide for but like big boy ed was like
Budweiser I can't hang campaign adverts
yes one of my boys is an actor and he's
done a few adverse before oh and you
guys he gets P my seat but he's a he's
one of the faces of the advert oh yeah
as opposed to I don't know just right
what you mean does he get from I'm like
supposing that tell everyone I was again
no we don't no one knows who he's I will
know he helped me off-camera he would
know is fair play
I know I've never got know many of you
boys but yes I was went for what Sheen
was it master of none yes
he wasn't out he was an effect or in it
season one he was an advert um and
that's when I he was just applying just
like applying he was like auditioning
yeah for like mad commercials yes he was
still making money from my commercial
yeah I was like that sounds both like
the best and worst thing ever
oh it sounds stressful for one because I
feel like we've with active person
especially in that kind of feel like add
fact in I don't think you never know
when your next gig would be so it's you
kind of still probably have to do like a
nine-to-five internship mmm
probably I'd assume so maybe I'd assume
so I don't know does your boy have a
nine-to-five
yeah he works oh and he's just sitting
on the side does it's not like but he
wants he wants
he does codon anybody wants to be an
actor like that sees a dream that sees
passion he does theater and all that
[ __ ] he's coding
it's quite a job yeah that's that's a
job the anime is your voice successful
well he's trying to be even more
successful
he just code him for a job and he's act
on size and actor yoni Saskia - he's got
he's got another plate coming out
thinks next week yeah man he's got a
plate coming out next week I think that
we towards the next month I don't know
if he misses tennis you know - he knows
him talking about him anyway mmm Bravo
I've gotta run oh of course you do
I haven't I didn't run for the last few
we haven't ran in for life the last few
weeks title on camera on camera you know
um
this whole like so say you're an
Instagram or whatever and then there's
like a story like it's someone's story
or they're posting or whatever and it's
always a go and it's like something
along the lines of I'm a queen so I
deserve a king or went except anything
is always I won't accept anything less
than the game yeah that [ __ ] slide on it
oh you and me both I'm bro I'm you I
yield oh I'm tired of it you and me both
with a capital y I'm tired bro is
exhausting taco but the thing is is well
like there's a few people that I'll see
right mmm
and then I think let me then usually a
drama Isaiah comp of it yeah but then I
saw it one the other day and I was like
right let me actually think about this
logically yeah because I fought I always
try and flip the perspective I say okay
so how would people look if I put on my
story I'm a king when deserve a queen
and I accept in anything less than a
queen yeah
first of all people are gonna be on my
case on ya rights from the jump
but yes can do it all right apparently
but then I fought right what qualifies
you to consider yourself a queen big man
mostly yes well there's there's a couple
years in particular once a couple me one
that's always on my stories or whatever
yeah
and this just all of that well that's
all it is all the time and it's like
alright I'm thinking what qualifies you
to consider yourself a queen mm-hmm then
when this person don't even go Jim
also what have you after this or you
just so I'm not asking her that I'm not
getting to that kind of discussion I'm
asking myself be much you don't even go
Jim I'm like how can you say yeah how
can you say because obviously when you
say I anything except in their king yeah
I'm assuming you have Stan yeah King
goes of court is considered a king I
doubt all you're gonna say is I just he
just needs to treat me nice yeah I doubt
that's what qualifies someone to be a
king so if you're gonna find you like if
your qualifying someone to be a king mmm
what qualifies you to be a queen mmm and
being going and going Jim and keeping
yourself tidy yeah should be they barely
even make the list yes that's basic yeah
yeah that's Bob to you if you ain't even
go in Jim if you ain't even go a Jim
don't ever tell tell me you don't you're
you're not accepting any pets or nothing
oh because like if I put myself as okay
let's say if I obviously I'm not but
what I'm saying is if I was that King
that you're looking for and I'm and
you're thinking rah that's the king this
is the King that I deserve yeah you
don't deserve me fam you can't even
bother go Jim I feel like with that I'm
I'm 50/50 I get where you're coming from
in terms of the Jim aspect unlike the
the basic minimum / basic necessity of
keeping yourself fit and proper blood
like that would or that not necessary
would or should where it's like a it's
like an entry level qualification to
becoming a king or queen yeah you should
look after yourself yeah and I agree
with that wholeheartedly wholeheartedly
with in the same breath a lot of a lot
of people don't
really
care about physical body type and it's
probably not our generation is probably
like just the older generation so a lot
of people that do say that that I have
seen are probably like their 30s and
stuff okay
yeah I've seen on my social medias or
like late twenties early thirties kind
of thing and sir
yes it's still kind of our generation
but it's an older generation where body
type isn't much of a what's the word I'm
looking for isn't much of a like entry
requirement yeah it's just the it's a
bonus if anything yeah yeah that's more
with like probably I'd say like African
community mmm Africa Caribbean community
as well that's what that's what I see
anyway okay that's what I see I'm not
saying it's my opinion it's just why see
ya yeah yeah that's why I set up a bit
5050 because I can understand both sides
of that of that argument but for me if
I'm portraying that are all I deserve as
a queen mmm in my head she's got a bit
she's got a go Jim personally though
she's crazy the things you gotta keep
her soft ID she doesn't have to be like
abs galore yeah yeah thank you you have
to that's the thing as well as like for
me it's not even a case of you need to
look uh sir I'm not even saying you
don't go Jim because you don't look us
that way what I'm saying is I know this
person doesn't go Jim all these people
couple people I'm thinking about they
died no they don't go Jim you wanna sign
up for nice a couple I mean one yeah
people I mean one I know for a fact they
don't go Jim okay and it's not even a
case of I want you to look this way you
know the feed to be a king even about
what you look like it's about what your
mental state is yeah is that you're
putting yourself in his pedestal yeah
you don't look after yourself you don't
look after yourself and like there's
people that are out there smoking
drinking whatever yeah yeah attitude
stinks but I've sometimes I think the
crux that it comes down to which annoys
me is especially in like this day and
age is that a woman will contain
to herself Queen stayers if she makes
our money mm-hm if she makes her own
money in their head Dairy Queen yeah if
they're independent and make their own
money where is that's exactly so for a
man to say I'll make my money that's
laughable yeah
that's laughable of course you do cause
everyone makes their own money because
and I breathe air em as well saying are
we there I washed with water like it's
just like I would love to see one day
someone say like I'm a queen did it
today but actually there I can look in
the burlap to be fair they actually are
yeah like they take care of themselves
they're a very kind person
they've got mad friends they make their
own money like they they're just looking
after people like rah you're actually
your queen like you deserve actually a
serious guy yeah but yet if you're just
driving your own car maker and my for
the love of God don't call yourself a
queen it pisses me off if I can pisses
me off if you have types of message a
couple times and then delete it the lead
story do that's oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] to
reply to that specific person
yeah I've half type to message like I
want to get into this and then I've I
have the forethought to think I don't
want to get into this because it's not
worth my energy I don't want to ruin
someone's day yeah and make them make
them defend themselves but I don't want
to put someone in the spot and be like
explain to me why you're a queen please
of course because that's a horrible
thing to put someone on those of course
and then I don't wanna I don't even have
the energy to argue about it so I just
leave it and some would say just maybe
don't stop looking at stories but I
can't yeah because I have to like have
an OCD behavior yeah if there's regular
people stories that are popping off my
[ __ ] even if I'm just clicking through
them I have to get through them yeah I
know you have to get a room you know no
I can't leave a story on my subconscious
mind knows what number is because
obviously I don't go through every
single story that's all my life cuz that
would take hours hours yeah but I don't
know what my unconscious
things yeah is enough yeah but I have to
go through them about going for a
half-day and I don't even want to annoys
me hey [ __ ] what was it what was it what
was it what was it sure when you're
asking me about the stories on Instagram
like that everyone posts the same [ __ ]
kind of thing yeah yeah yeah ever like
something in the gym someone singing
along to something in the car I grow up
seeing kind of the same [ __ ] I fall
victim of all of that you know I mean I
always post [ __ ] in the gym I always put
what were in the club same I always post
[ __ ] what I say especially in a car but
I don't drive anymore but yeah the
chorus the car is the one for me I'm
always I'm always posting this because I
live in my car oh gosh it is the
funniest [ __ ] yeah so and I'd like to
say that cuz you're my boy it's so
creative so if anyone doesn't follow
this card is the ground please follow it
please follow it all the descriptions
and all the details are in our honor in
the links below in everything please
follow us it's so funny like it's like
when you were talking about like the few
episodes ago were talking about the
thing you wanted to be a dog with me
back when we had my space and stuff my
space imaginative bro that's imaginative
and I understand the reason why I didn't
do at that time cuz that era didn't even
understand yeah it wasn't a thing what's
the word I'm looking for social media
committee yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
either a professional comedian or
nothing you're even like a professional
comedian or you're like the funny guy
within your area but none of this skit
[ __ ] stick
oh stop making skits don't arrow off
your own back you desire making my space
skits that would have been a terrifying
place for me to be been laughable I
would have had to have no friends so
would it be laughable bro of course I'm
not in the way I wanted it to be oh oh
to be laughed at
you'd be laughs at you and I would've
been loft out of my friendship group out
of the school so yeah but yeah boy I
don't I don't know I just love I love
being creative about know that was clear
and I'll spend hours doing it I know you
I know you but I feel like it's
worthwhile because it's some funny [ __ ]
bro gratis
that's that means a lot coming from you
because you're very honest I'm very
honest and if it wasn't funny you'll
just tell me straight I'll love your
face I don't need to be around the bush
cuz blame but I think you know what I
was having this this is another one I'll
[ __ ] have in the other day actually
for someone about that specific thing
and I think that's why it annoys me is
something that wouldn't annoy anyone
else but it annoys me yeah massively
yeah is that people who have AK this is
what I was talking about so you know
when we were speaking the other day
about when I picked you up about what
was it when we were talking about
podcast and stuff like that yeah and
people who are already successful yeah
I've been putting my craft or whatever
yeah into a certain area yeah and then
they can branch out on other areas and
immediately be successful yeah of course
um but that's okay because they put the
work in else yeah I that I stand by that
mmm but I also don't like when people
use their celebrity to do stuff that
they're really bad at so comedies are a
big one for me okay I don't like people
who are not funny who tried to be funny
though who perhaps of correctly not find
like that have excelled in other things
but they're naturally funny like perfect
one is like social media people so
there's an example is what actually
broke theirs
what is it obviously with them I got
flies up in here
I've got flies up in here you're sorted
bear oh I've got flies in here I'm
getting angry
it's getting so guys I'm sorry I'm
getting so angry this flies in here
anyway there's what is it the bath bath
bath thing on Instagram cassia can see a
Elise Henry wherever she must have
jumped on tick tock or something every
day and she's trying to do all these
funny skits and they're so unfunny is
painful to watch
I hate it like that is so unfunny
brother it's painful
I've got another example you follow
simeon panda yes I follow [ __ ] so
Hitler
gotta speak for those who don't know
simeon panda is an internet weighs a
bodybuilder from england london and but
he now lives in LA with these misses
he's well known like he is known for
bodybuilding got like 9 million
followers for date i think about more
than that
i've been following for ages and he
built his career and his repertoire on
bodybuilding obviously when people moved
to LA they love this social media they
love this skin still of this comedy
aspect and he's fired to do some maybe
like the first when he first moved out
to LA I don't looking at her like why
this is the biggest amount dog [ __ ] like
why why would you ever why is not funny
it's not your likes your what's the one
with looking for it's not you don't mean
to do it yeah it's not your lane lanius
they understand people on a branch I get
that and I think the reason why he did
do it is because he's getting into
acting yes I think he's got a movie
coming did a movie and his come out
alright his little clips that he put on
his move look terrible as well yeah
terrible but there's only something
things you can do me because it's a big
guys are ya gonna be like a fighter he
was like a SWAT that some [ __ ] but like
it annoyed I don't know why I noise me
but it annoys me so much because I feel
like is that something if you're gonna
do something it's like to me it's like
would you do it if you didn't already
have the following things oh they're
definitely wouldn't you would never do
yeah III followers would you be making
funny little skits in your room and [ __ ]
like that if the answer's no they just
don't do it ever don't do ever so don't
do ever if you didn't want to do it
before or if it doesn't like interest
you whatsoever
or yeah like like that if you didn't
already have such a massive following
that you can pretty much get away with
doing whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
would you have done it and if yes no
then just leave it they definitely won't
leave it to the people that are actually
funny actually funny and that's not me
saying I think I'm funny yeah but that's
like I've done once before we're in my
head I'm like are that's funny yeah and
then I've done it execute it look to the
video yeah I thought that's not funny
and then deleted it oh really yeah bear
times oh really it's not a case of
someone Tommy once
time that I'm funny so I can just do
whatever I wanna be every rain before
yeah I'm critical of myself if I look at
it I think that's not funny yeah I won't
post it but yeah that's exactly like me
um if I just randomly start at this and
then for [ __ ] it I'm gonna get into
politics and they just started ranting
about politics going off oh boy yeah
yeah and the eco geographical social
anomic all that [ __ ] I'm just running my
mouth because I've got the following to
get away with it [ __ ] about politics
like that's one thing I could never give
a fro I was like I don't think it's not
ever with when we're in Amsterdam yeah
and then we were in the uber and then
the guy was giving us a history lesson
about Amsterdam and then he was getting
into it and it was mad interesting and
he was like yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
started talking about like British
people like the wars the bridges were
gone and they're like Canada and all
this [ __ ] and I was like cool that's
interesting that's interesting and not
kind of like how Europe have come
together and suffering it all kind of
blended into dike and then we got to the
EU and then it gotten to brexit and as
soon as he said brexit I was so not I
think he asked what he brought us
and I didn't answer bro he literally us
us did you vote to stay or to leave and
it's like first well don't ever ask
someone how they voted you don't know me
yeah don't if you've got an agenda
already if you're already telling me oh
it's such a shame that Britain left and
stuff like that yeah don't ask me what I
voted don't and want yes I voted to stay
but don't ask me don't ask me and when
he asks I was just like why is it why we
came into politics prof just leave in
only cares about politics
bro and what people do care obviously
but it's a weird one for me it's a weird
one for me like I care but it's like I
just don't have enough of a foundation
minyan yeah I agree I don't know
anything about it aaseesh it's about I
have no idea so I don't say [ __ ] about
yeah I
but yeah man is weird like people get
invested
invested I also bought one thing one
thing that my brother taught me one time
I wrote my brother for everything not
writing but I listen to anything yes
yeah one thing he said is he always
votes for exactly who he wants to vote
for not for so if it's a case of say
there's ten parties yeah but obviously
it's going to go between labour and the
Tories right always he won't if he
doesn't [ __ ] with either of them or if
he aligns his values more with like the
Liberal Democrats or something like that
he'll vote for the Liberal Democrats
regardless if if they're even in the
running yeah vote for them because like
he holds dear he likes politics he holds
did like the true democracy of like you
have the only way voting works is if you
actually vote for the party that you
think should win yeah not who you think
is going to win or who is more on my
team one or team to know here like most
people will vote like if they agree with
nothing on this side and agree with
maybe one thing on this side they'll
vote for this side even if there's
another team over there that they agree
wholeheartedly no they're not in the
right to win they won't waste their vote
people don't want to waste their vote
yeah but technically speaking it's a
waste as they've always they were
focused and I said everyone keeps doing
that then everyone could agree with team
seven mmm everyone could but no one's
working for them because they think
they're not even in the running but if
actually everyone aligned the votes
where they're supposed to be aligned and
voted over here then guess we're one
happy team seven one is an anemic win
yeah but yeah that that one thing even I
don't get into politics that one thing
that he explained to me is like a few
years ago now a few years ago
explained to me I was out rah okay fair
point so now every time every time it's
very time yeah I just hit him up on my
way you want a who to vote for I know
just give me the CliffsNotes
keep me the summary just let me know cuz
I can't be asked yeah do the reason I
asked to do the research it's long funny
it's so like oh my days oh so delicious
yeah I want to get you into you
I've tried it before I've had monster a
few times really what these ones yeah
you've given me some really and you just
weren't [ __ ] you with it yes yeah
they're okay but I haven't I don't drink
it enough to like you said I doesn't you
don't understand enough you're not gonna
have an opinion I don't drink yeah I
don't I will go to the shop and buy a
monster like ever I never would if you
give me one I drink it dropping by one I
do every day I know you do I spend money
I spend at least he's probably what over
is over a hundred panel mob I'll write
out the other day how much is monster
how much is it can one something one
something oh if it's a workday I have to
okay three pound there's three pound for
pound let's say max let's say four pound
max times stay well four times 320i 120
pound oh my god Yeji oh [ __ ] it's crazy
how these guys make money not even like
monster per se but like anyone if you've
got a habit like smokers for example bro
oh my goodness I was speaking some guys
at work and they said you to smoke two
packs a day two packs of 20 a blade like
how much that cost I'm probably like I
think it's like a five or a tenner for a
pack of cigarettes I think it's like
five or four ten and maybe a telephone
at the 20 pack I don't know I'm guessing
yeah why does my cigarettes anyway and
he just said you smoke a pack and a half
a day to two packs a day bro no day
doing that that is you can't make money
that's thousands of pounds bro thousands
of pounds it's crazy
who smokes fam in this day and age who
smokes millions there's an old lady that
lives downstairs caught of smokey that's
the only time I've ever seen I don't
think she ever leaves her house apart
from spicy burger to go on the doorstep
of smoke and like I saw a meme the other
day and it was like who wakes up who
looks at a cigarette 8 a.m. I thinks YUM
oh [ __ ] I need that bro time to wake up
to smoke that's so disgusting when you
smell it you know how can you wake up
first thing in the morning my ahh this
is what I hate about this country I'm
sure they do it in every country but
this is
the one thing I hate in this country
anytime someone says to me like chav hmm
or something like that or [ __ ] or
whatever this is what I think in this
country well if I ever think of scum in
England the first image that comes to my
head is like an middle-aged stroke as
you know middle-aged kind of overweight
woman mmm first thing in the morning on
a doorstep with a cup of tea
shaggy bedhead hairs all over the gaff
dressing-gown and smoking effect and
it's cold cold cold outside and is there
firm in it they're just firm in the
freezing [ __ ] cold just so they can
have this cigarette
it makes me [ __ ] sick it was funny
because the person described is someone
that used to work in my school when I
was in year [ __ ] we're here was I in I
think I was in year 7 was only a 7 I was
in year 10 I remember I was in second
school anyway cuz I remember I used to
play football in yeah he's playful for
my school in year ten it was a ten yeah
11 and there was this lady that dropped
me home one day she was like one of the
caretakers and mums or something like
that they used to walk into school cuz
we live close to each other I remember
and she said she stopped off she's going
to shop yeah she dropped me off from a
football game because we lived close
okay drop me off from a football game
she said I just get my milk come off the
cigarettes sad Oh everyday needs have
tea and cigarettes and she's the person
you described bro disgusting but exactly
the person he described Dustin woman
hench and all she wants is teen
cigarettes that's that's it as soon as
he said I just it just triggered me
rough stuff ah that makes me ill stuffer
let me speak ill and another thing when
people is I don't know why these things
coming off when I ask someone what do
you have for breakfast yeah
and they say coffee you ever get that
every day it pisses me the [ __ ] off
what'd you have for breakfast coffee
there's nothing for me to even say ya
know it's just like gamma face if
they're like I'm stopping a waiver for
reference coffee you sue me Bob shut up
[Laughter]
guys I want to get into gambling I've
told this guy so he he said he messaged
me saying the text was word-for-word
what gambling app do you use this is
funny when you say about that when I
texted it just look normal
gambling app that's how you know you're
an amateur
and um it's Wharf I can average I'm I
said gambling app bro that's funny I
don't know why is enough use I want to
gamble you don't want to gamble bro it's
a thing is I know it I know I don't this
is a I don't know the words to describe
it moment it's a downhill spiral bro I'm
well aware but I don't want to to gamble
but I'm certain because my life has been
so unlucky yeah I'm certain I won't
spend more than a pound of time you say
that cuz that's how I started but you're
you're you're a gambler you've been a
gamblers as the day I met you
every time we used to go to a casino
your sweat in fact pull me away from the
table bro I can't let a love roulette we
were always gonna get trapped always I
lose I lose lose lose such an addiction
I got into scratched cards recently yeah
have you ever won of the scratch cards
I've been like a pound or two
I'm wide one more thing to pick the most
everyone is a fiver and this was when I
was working I got rid of the mark I
remember because I bought one one it got
the cash I bought another scratch kind
of think that's what you're supposed to
do but yeah I I've been buying them I
win like a pound or two
mmm and then I've already I've already
given up yeah because I'm just not
winning I'm just I'm no I'm not a
gambler mmm I just not in my blood so I
reckon if I get a little gambling up on
my phone
deposit the tenner just do a ridiculous
accumulator but something that I say
ridiculous something that's not so out
race that's never gonna happen
something tangible but the odds because
there's an accumulator
odds are in your favor I didn't put a
pound down hopefully I'll get 100 back
or something like that and then we'll
just keep it shaking like that yeah but
you need to be I know I know that's the
way you want to go about it to make it
like easy breezy like hard and stuff
yeah yeah well you're never gonna win
those like you're never gonna win those
why because you're not it's just never
gonna happen because for you to put a
pound on or two pounds on to get like a
hundred pound back roughly you would
have to put ridiculous bets on that bets
that most likely not gonna come in yeah
that makes sense but that if you put
like a tenner on or fiver on and put
like 10 15 games accumulation then
you'll probably get a hundred pound back
yeah one pound OOP and you're not really
that much back because their odds will
always be stacked against you if you're
gonna bet for like favorite teams or
people they think may win a blah blah so
if you put in a partner - you're not
gonna get more than probably 20 to 40
pound in my opinion anyway mmm so that's
just my that's just my professional
opinion obviously as a human mature a
gambler and whatnot maybe I'll just
leave altogether then today I want you
to get into it you want me to I want you
to just like just to see what it's like
just is for you I don't I don't think
I'll bet on the footboard oh why would
you want maybe MBA mmm true true true
true because you got more an
understanding about that yeah I only
ever belt football I came so close like
twice in the past two weeks for oh yeah
I was I think I said it - I was showing
Bella I had a 16 it was no it was on
Thursday just gone it was the Europa at
a 16 match accumulator
all over 1.5 got us two girls minimum 14
of them came in
I bought a tenner on and the return was
797 bar [ __ ] helped Arsenal scored
one and so I think again the Ghent game
was one nil as well or fumin she need
two goals two goals cuz we've been
laughing for techni that's why it's an
adrenaline rush and that's why I know is
I know exactly why that's nice
I've seen people fair I've seen you
checking your phone every 4 seconds
throw a refresh in the team I saw Louis
doing it one time we were swimming man
had to bring his phone into the swimming
pool he's just on the edge every 10
seconds for fresh and refreshing
it's cause of the cash out thing yeah
there was no such thing as cash out no
one would be on their phone that much
yeah yeah yeah shout bets are where it's
at purely because let's say you're
getting a bookie scared you are getting
a bookie up but they give you I said
like the one that I won when I was like
yours last time last year so I put a
tenner on on like five games five no six
games five of them came in and then the
last game started like 8:00 p.m. why I
cashed out like seven hundred pounds but
the when if I the other game came in I
would have one night 1,200 pounds any
event this game and the game didn't come
in luckily I cashed out it I mean so
yeah if those if you never have cash out
you're like [ __ ] I'm always cash you
know I'm always gonna cash out that's
why I say that's why I've said when I
first fire I could have cashed out and
the other day for night II quit Thursday
one yeah is there there was like seven
game started us 555 and the other like
seven games or eight game started at 8
p.m. so all my games are 555 came in and
my cash I at that time was 90 quid or 97
quibbles to top what would you have won
I would have won 797 oh okay I mean yeah
see I'm not cashing now exactly I say
but the more and more the games start to
start like let's say it's 8:05 and like
8:15 your cash shot will drop because
all those gives us light enough so the
odds are back in yeah if I had cashed
out I would have been up because I lost
the bet
show me but it's a risk that's why scam
believes the risk cool man but it's not
mine I think I don't think I wouldn't I
don't I'm not advocate of it because
it's basically it's basically a waste of
money but when you win it's a [ __ ]
rush man I'm gonna bet when you win it's
a rush right so wrap this up before we
bore these people to death yep